[Applause]
right ladies good evening
yes yes all from up north yes yes matt
what's on the menu
pan roasted pigeon breasted pigeon
on a mushrooms asparagus
salad dressing
okay right starter let's do one together
yeah let's go
right what's the secret about cooking
pigeon don't overdo it don't overdo it
exactly now they'll be marinated
in thyme garlic pigeon in
yeah and that's the sort of noise you
want to hear yeah just that nice little
sizzle
mushrooms in yeah yeah touch of shallots
and a little touch of garlic in there
yes okay
asparagus in what's in the vinaigrette
cherry vinegar good
groundnut oil good and uh well
good sprinkle with chives right pigeon
out
yeah that's just gonna sit there and
rest
salad uh rocket some walnuts in there
yep plate mushrooms yeah on
some asparagus on a little bit of cellar
on there it's a warm salad
and then from the breast turn it over so
it's flat side down
and just slice the breast and then
finally we'll have a little bit of
vinaigrette over the end and look bingo
anything complicated there
no chef no sure chef okay first order
come on girl okay on order four covers
table three yes four pidgey salad four
skate four pan per do
yes yes yes i like law and order in my
kitchen
[Music]
we all know each other through the
police force
i love everything about food i just you
know love trying new things and
go get a bun this big without having a
passion for food
we're used to people being fiery with us
so if worse comes to the worst we can
always handcuff him to the cooker
bring it on gordon
he's not even going to be able to swear
and if he does it's probably cody he's
going down
we're going to sell 150 plates no
problem
just be very very careful when you're
cooking these yeah they're overcooking
seconds yeah
very quickly with your tongs out quickly
good
good five let's go
come on elise yeah yeah sure why did you
join the police force well my modeling
three never took off really so
and you enjoy it i do yeah it's uh
full-on it's a rewarding job
packed with emotion no yeah upsetting i
try and use cooking to get over that
good service please you're happy with
that maz yes yeah
yeah so my table 12. let's go
[Music]
jamie
[Music]
how are you hi everyone nice to see you
again thank you for having me back
good to see you is this in the way for
the shot then
right listen excuse me how many have you
got now
three four if you count that one for the
show
a month later you said bastard you're
still carrying it around yeah but i had
to pick it up today and i said i'll pick
up gordon's one and then they went which
one i said didn't gordon
you're an entertainer you should be
winning those how many mission stands
have you got seven
yeah i bought them on ebay
okay good to see you again lovely to be
here thank you for having me we enjoyed
our starter the asparagus was nice
what about the pigeon pigeon's all white
but a pigeon belongs in trafalgar square
no it doesn't actually sit there's a
woodland pigeon jonathan
you're quite a fussy child when you're a
child you were sort of when i was a
child you know what i would eat yeah i
would eat eggs
my brothers called me egg boy and i was
in the top bunk as well
but you must have something more than
sort of eggs well my mum was an okay
cook but you know we were
i'm not you know pleading public here
but we weren't well off family
so she'd sometimes do a casual at the
weekend but it was just a big old bit of
me
simmering and she's got a can of baked
beans in there anything she had
available
and that was fine all we used to have i
used to like chicken and chips when we
had that occasionally
you know but it wasn't we didn't have
much else we used to have a lot of food
that you buy in stores like i remember
you remember vesta
yeah they used to make the kind of beef
risotto that was the most exotic food
i've ever had
right i want to talk about fanny credit
please don't amazing woman and and this
year we lost a campaign to help find a
new fan
you're looking for your own fanny i
understand that and i applaud that but
why not
just do what more commerce used to do a
little bit of lippy a long blonde weave
double bubble you never know you might
win a bathtub you're the one with the
man boobs
i've actually not really got man boobs
what i've got though is i'm carrying a
lot of weight down there feel that feel
that down there go on
[Laughter]
so probably not should we have a little
look at it jb please have a look at this
so this is you back in 1987 yeah
as a skinny mini your show was the most
successful cookie show ever i think
probably yes
what do you think was the key to that
success that i could cook
but i don't believe you had any formal
training as a cook did you what do you
call formal training for bigger cook
there aren't people like that on tv
anymore no they really aren't because
you're actually
saying clearly i'm very good at what you
do what kind of advice would you give to
any woman out there that's thinking of
becoming
the next sort of tv cook what you're
looking for really some of the
personality but but it's a difficult
thing because you don't want someone to
be false
well thousands of them have applied have
a quick look at this all right so this
is these are amateur fannies yeah the
amateur fan is
ready all i don't know is that your
dough should feel like a fat lady's ass
perfect with one hand why is she in a
row
would you like me to blow do you want to
be nigella
yeah in here i've got about 100 grams of
chickpea flour
and there you have one of the most
delicious
you know i won't show you my my tips on
tv but i might show you my tattoos see
like that it looks like she wears an egg
on her head it's a terrible haircut it's
like a hairs on backwards
straight in there now i'm tempted to
drink it myself but no we'll put it in
the dish
i think she might be emotionally damaged
i could see that they've all they're all
obviously quite confident yes
they've all got different things to work
for them against them they need to be
strong
charismatic and someone's not going to
melt under the pressure you want to get
one of those female uh bodybuilders with
the long clitorises
[Laughter]
i'll get your main course sorted
the pigeon was lovely actually i really
like the asparagus with it as well as
the warner
one of my friends had the same obviously
pigeon it was a bit more cooked
and it was a lot nicer
right results ladies starters okay jb
okay here we go
now ladies the number
paid of customers before they're starter
it's 34 out of 50. 34. not bad
why is that loose um undercooked
undercooked i'll
get that i'll tell you to wear pink is
perfect when it's brown
it's fast don't go down yeah don't let
it get to you
bounce back yes yes honest stations
let's go ladies yes
next on the menu never mind the scallops
will my wetsuit stay dry why is it like
this
when you get to this stage you're always
bursting for a pee
time for the main course mouth-watering
roast skate with beetroot and parmesan
that is 100 pig's blood and i share a
bloody awful drink with janet street
dracula
oh [ __ ] tastes by enticing
welcome back to the expert time for the
main course
pan roasted skate ring delicious very
very sweet easy to get hold of
and more importantly very cheap pack dry
season hot pan olive oil
butter now the fish has taken a
completely different color
based
and that butter is on the verge of
becoming a benoisette
and not brown butter
[Applause]
beautiful slides off pull it back leave
that to rest for two minutes now the
garnish
lettuce
salt pepper
balsamic vinegar
olive oil rosemary
[Applause]
30 seconds hot pan
beetroot and look at the glaze on that
beet root now
capers parmesan
parsley vinaigrette
as the parmesan starts to melt take it
off
literally 10 seconds in the pan
out and well that beats spinach any day
[Applause]
[Music]
that has to be the perfect way of
bringing escape back to life
pan roast escape with beetroot and
parmesan
done
joe yeah the skate's sticking yeah was
the pan hot enough
uh because look let me show you
something look yeah not enough color
come on
if it's boiling a completely different
flavor oh good yeah
yeah quite thick though huh yeah there's
little big ones then
we like a big one don't we got to baste
them you don't base them they're not
going to cook on top
yes beetroot in good
nice right good good watch where you
place them in there
watch careful careful careful careful oh
where's them fry your brigade when you
need them
watch your fingers lisa lisa that's nice
beautiful color
yes sure come on these you're doing very
well damian let's go yeah are you all
looking this [ __ ] miserable
why is that when i'm concentrating when
i'm trying to work hard you like this at
work i always look miserable
good good pull more wire
here we go it looks lovely thank you
watch out here's the food snob with the
big gob
in here is a food packed full of vitamin
b12 iron and protein
which is produced in britain but
unbelievably almost nobody eats it
in fact we waste 36 million
tons of it a year which is a dreadful
shame
i'm gonna get you all to eat blood
we should eat more of it but us brits
find the thought of cooking with blood
pretty hard to stomach now that is
something
i definitely wouldn't be putting past my
lips i think it's the thought of it
that puts you off straight away yeah if
you was going to tell me it was going to
be good for you i would i would i would
taste it yeah i would eat it does sound
a bit sort of like hammer house of
horror type of approach to cooking no it
feels a little bit
too devil worshiping for me i'm not a
vampire
[Music]
it might be out of fashion but
protein-rich pig's blood
has traditionally been used in cooking
i'm going to try some of the world's
best blood recipes so i'm here at this
abattoir to source some prime fresh
ingredient as in all abattoirs the pigs
are stunned before being bled
my bucket
i'm taking my blood to renowned butcher
david lishman
to learn how to make the classic british
blood dish black pudding
great it's very rare that we actually
get fresh blood nowadays
after cooling for a couple of hours the
blood oxidizes and turns brown
the blood is mixed with barley oatmeal
pork fat and lots of herbs and spices
and poured into a sausage machine are
these bits of intestine then
yeah it looks like a kind of a
birth control device oh my word
lovely this goes into the boiler now
right
okay for 45 minutes to an hour
excellent good nice firm mealy british
black pudding
yeah it's good right i'll have a bit of
that to take home
there's a lot more to cooking with blood
than black pudding
andy holt is an enthusiastic blood chef
who's collected recipes from all over
the world
i'm here to learn how to cook his
special italian
blood dessert so we're just mixing the
egg and the caster sugar together
what better way to popularize blood with
the british than by
appealing to our sweet tooth and into
that
we're adding melted chocolate just
sounds like a chocolate mousse so far
yeah and then the next thing we're
putting in is the blood
now why on earth did the italians dream
up making a pudding using blood
in a way it's a way to to use up a
valuable resource because the blood is
actually very good for you obviously
it's full of iron
it's full of vitamins
why andy look at that superb i pasted it
you absolutely promised me honestly
back memories that squealing pig
those exactly like chocolate mousse i'm
now convinced that blood
is not only good for you delicious
beautiful but it's also
tasty all i've got to do now is persuade
gordon
right gordon what i want to do for you
right it's italian pancakes called
romancini
it's like a classic pancake mix and
instead of milk
you've got blood i've never had a blood
pancake you know that are you a kid
yeah no water no milk no just blood
and this is all pig's blood bloody hell
oh it's not something i donated earlier
no
geez look at that it doesn't look that
nice does it
actually looks like melted chocolate so
just get over it
okay cheesy all right let it cook first
before you flip it so what did you put
inside the pancake or would you actually
serve them like that
i think for the of testing i am
converting you
you should have nothing but a blood
pancake oh no
do you know what that looks like what i
imagine your scrotum looks like
that's a bit
look at that just the smell of it though
ah
it actually smells like fried blood
smells nice
it smells nice
it's very rubbery ah moaning
you can't taste the blood did you
swallow
there's nothing absolutely nothing wrong
it's [ __ ] disgusting
janet i don't have a problem with it as
i couldn't persuade you to
eat the pancake how about shot of blood
you're turning [ __ ] hey seriously
your feet is golden
and that is 100 pigs blood
drink it you put lead in your paper saw
oh [ __ ] it's fantastic
i'm not the man i thought you were janet
i know you're a pensioner but now you're
a bloodsucking pensioner
janet that is not nice
[ __ ] [ __ ] vampire
no charts oh
[Music]
i'm heading down the dorset coast to go
diving one of my all-time favorite foods
spots
no speed cameras here is that [ __ ] up
i adore scallops and i've stirred them
on all my menus
but most of them are fished on a
commercial scale using dredging which
can damage the seabed
the sustainable way to catch them is to
go diving and pick them up by hand
which is what i'm going to do today hand
dive scallop
especially is something that is
considered a bit of a jewel in the crown
phenomenal
i'm off to meet tom whittle in weymouth
who's been diving for scallops since he
was 12.
have you got any shoes yeah i've got
some somewhere did you never wear it
right uh temperature-wise what's gonna
be like down there 14 degrees
if we're lucky yeah yeah if we're lucky
yeah
serious cheers and are they um
in abundance it depends sort of where
you go but normally what you do is
basically get down there and if there's
tons then you just work them yeah and if
there's none then you just swim like
[ __ ] until you find them
that's bad good ready bits
yeah i've heard that before
we're heading out to the blackhawk wreck
where we'll start our dive
marine life congregates on wrecks and
nearby there's an abundance of scallops
how big are they average size probably
about that here really
about that because in london at the
moment getting them from the south coast
and the west coast but
they're costing about three pound fifty
four pounds each each
each that's like commercial scholarly
[Laughter]
the reason that hand dive scallops are
so expensive is that they are incredibly
hard to catch
and a diver will only pick up a fraction
of the whole of a commercial fisherman
um they're difficult to see aren't they
yeah yeah they can be i mean especially
uh
if they've buried themselves into the
sand but it's all about getting your
eye into it yeah
why is it like this when you get to this
stage you're always bursting for a pee
it's it's the way that it is it's the
rule of the game unbelievable
i feel like that [ __ ] condom again
now what are these things
[Music]
[Music]
visibility down here today is terrible
which makes spotting scallops that are
nestled into the sand
almost impossible
[Music]
[Music]
here comes the beach file
stand back
[Applause]
elegant isn't it well done
good quality scallops ah lovely right
beach time
tom normally saves his scallops for
supper but i want to eat mine straight
away
the fresher the better right
fantastic they look amazing can i open
them
and clean them yeah so a scalloped
tartar
yeah basically a raw dye scallop
mixed with lime yeah chervil
and then a little bit of creme fraiche a
mascarpone
cheese yeah absolutely amazing
dive open the scallop and then eat
look i mean they're still pulsating now
i'm feeling it's still
it's extraordinary mix some creme fresh
with mascarpone cheese
lime zest lime juice
some chervil and salt and pepper
right dice the scallops in
and all we do now is just fold that in
there
it's so exciting eating raw scallops so
i'm going to serve the scab tata inside
the lettuce leaf
so just open up the heart of the baby
gem lettuce quite a robust leaf this so
they can take the scallop
absolutely delicious and there we are a
very simple
scalloped tartar fire away buddy
cheers
there you go now so tasty
ten times better to use hand dived and
not dredged
and i'd rather pay double for a hand
dive yeah
than cheap dredge collapse that taste of
grit cheers cheers
scallops away
[Music]
first time i had skates and the fish was
great
so disappointing and just greasy
the beetroot was gorgeous it had little
bits of cheese in which gave a really
unusual flavor
okay ladies results of the main course
chefs matt how do you think you did
i put it all right 29 out of 50.
what why uh the one just been big reason
too greasy
unbelievable you know i personally felt
you did a [ __ ] good job
you can pull it back yes come on
yes next on the menu
sarah cox reveals all in the recipe
challenge but instead i asked the entire
table if we could all have a gang bang
i give olympic athletes a run for the
money with my fast food
jonathan ross files a police complaint
you want to suck my what
i said hold on i'm being harassed
welcome back to the f word now time for
another celebrity challenge and it's
time for me also to beat sarah cox
confident to meet me i'll beat me but
beat you beat me all right uh nice to
meet you yes i am quite confident
yesterday that's your board there okay
madam good luck yes yes good luck to you
too sir
so sarah's making a chili con carne i'm
doing exactly the same minced beef
fresh oregano um paprika sweet paprika
kidney beans
slightly pure in the garlic so it's not
so intense and then finished with really
nice vine tomatoes so it gives that
really nice sort of rich
dark peppery flavor but not too spicy
so for sarah's chili's special chopped
onion a bit of chopped garlic
might chuck in a bit of red pepper some
uh good beef here i don't believe it's
hereford but it is british beef
good got a bit of tomato puree i might
chuck in a bit of wine
chopped tomatoes kidney beans i can it's
like the bung in method basically i just
bung it all in do that and then drink a
bit of wine
uh and my secret ingredient baked beans
uh you've got an amazing food background
your father's a a bee farmer in bolton
is that right it certainly is
he does it mainly for the breeding
really you know i think he'll send one
in when he's got a big farm bill
and so does he have to have a collection
of bull semen every other month well
he's got a good stock bowl and he's got
he
imports them from canada and that's
really got longer legs or something
so you grew up eating lots of meat yes
well yeah
pigs cows did you ever get attached to
them yeah i really did i really really
the piglets
charlotte's web was all the rage wasn't
it now i know it sounds like i need
therapy from this story but i did
actually used to go to the
to the abattoir with my dad when he
loaded all the pigs in oh really
and i used to cry myself to sleep and
then wake up when it was all over you
know i never went into the albertoire i
don't know
now but the nice thing about it you
understood exactly from an early age
where meat comes from
yeah exactly so i've got diamonds in the
back garden the main
objective is to get the kids up to speed
exactly where it comes from and b
i'm in that sort of debatable mood
whether or not to take them to the
abattoir
and show them the final thing uh i
wouldn't be expensive though years of
therapy that you have to pay
for either that will turn out to be
[ __ ] vegetarians aren't they
oh i can hear some noise in your pant
i'm happy huh it's sizzling
it's alive it's in there so you've got
onions garlic beef in there what else is
in there
there's my fresh chili in there i'm
gonna blend this beef
off and then i'm gonna whack in a glass
of red wine and let that bubble away
i'm using uh liam perrin what's your
secret ingredient
i've got a tin of baked beans you're
using what
can i bake beans i tend to bake beans
yeah no
so red wine with baked beans i can't
wait to taste it together
the one thing i've always admired about
you you know that if you're a bit like
me you speak your mind yeah what's the
most embarrassing thing you've ever said
in your entire life
oh no there's my mum had taken out all
the stuff from her pub
on the christmas meal i meant for us to
all go out and dance
but instead i asked the entire table if
we could all have a gang bang
and everyone just went completely silent
and my mum just went ashen and i didn't
know what i meant and i still to this
day i kind of meant there's a word out
there that isn't that but at the ripe
old age of 32 now you're fully aware of
what gangbang is now don't you
yeah yeah i mean not from personal
experience obviously but
no i learned quickly after actually what
it was and i was like all right
i'm now gonna have my tomatoes these big
beef tomatoes are
perfect they're very juicy and they're
full of flavor so with tomatoes is it
fine
to keep the skin on because i always
want to put fresh tomato in and i think
oh do i have to don't come in boiling
water and get the skin off because
something like a chili something easy
and straightforward like that keeping
the skin on
it's absolutely fine you know that
that's cool you've got a great figure
you're very slim do you watch carefully
what you eat or do you just sort of work
out the same time
i love food yep i can be quite happily
eating breakfast and i'll be planning
what i want for lunch and what i want
for dinner
you eat well yeah i didn't i used to
model and i didn't eat well at
all yeah it was like seven and a half
stone it was ridiculous like my knees
were fatter than my thighs it was like
19.
i lived on like you know malbolites and
coffee
how long were we modeling for a couple
of years i mean without success
successful i still managed to fit in
some shifts behind my mum's bar at the
pub
you traveled across the world uh modeled
in yeah in seoul in south korea on two
trips
did they ever try to make you eat a dog
out there in terms of that i did eat a
dog
i didn't know i'd eaten dog until i got
to the joint of the bone and then i
realized it wasn't chicken because it
was kind of a different
yeah structure what are the taste of
this is just deep fried meat like kind
of like chicken
really so they both simmer down for 20
minutes okay then the blind tasters will
taste them
and you'll lose fast food doesn't have
to mean baked beans
[Music]
i've run eight marathons 26 long hard
miles each
and if there's one thing i've learned is
that eating right
is just as important as the training so
you'd think that two super fast athletes
training for the olympics would be
eating a varied diet in between training
but they're not and their excuses they
say they've got no time
we train in the morning three or four
hours you know maybe have half an hour
for lunch
um and then back in training in the
afternoon so it's not six days a week so
it's busy schedule
lunchtime's a struggle because it's on
the rush it's on the go
and uh it's just food for fuel there's
nothing interesting about it at all all
i e is just a ready-made pasta pot
it's literally just pasta mixed with a
bit of chicken bit sauce
just because we're training for the
olympics we don't need anything special
in particular we just need to eat
good amounts of the right stuff i want
to learn how to cook something nice
quick tasty and i want to be able to
impress my girlfriend that i can
actually cook
so i've come to meet best mates chris
and andy to help them be as fast in the
kitchen
as they are on the track lightning that
looked
bloody fast yeah um how many times a day
do you train
twice a day twice a day today five days
a week six days a week six days a week
i mean that's extraordinary for one goal
an olympic gold
that's the old it's the olympics yeah
who's the fastest
well he won't deny it it's me his
personal best is better but the last
time we raced
a live tv you're going to hit him i took
him out he took him out i took you out
we'll do me a favor
take me out i want to see just how fast
you are yeah
you sure 15 stone 40 years of age yeah
so go easy on the old man yes good luck
let's go
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
i felt like [ __ ] shrek going over
there yeah i'll try the sprinting you
know that
screen's better so it's all in the
posture question yeah yeah
sprinting's better
don't
[ __ ]
you know i'm [ __ ] now you just
confirmed you're fast
on the track i'm gonna show you how to
be fast in the kitchen
ready when you caught your breath
right time-wise lunch you've got what
half an hour half an hour max
yeah run me through a normal lunch what
did you have yesterday pasta pot
and that's it that's it a pasta pop
that's a faster part i mean it looks
boring
it is boiling yes you must be bored with
it by now no
god i am fed up with it pasta doesn't
have to be boring you know that
so i'm gonna come up with three very
exciting pasta dishes we're gonna be
fast
furious and delicious first recipe
spaghetti white tomato sauce
basil chili and finished with prawns
[Music]
pasta is the ultimate fast food and
something i eat when i'm training for
the marathon
how did you find that good how'd you
find america yeah it was tough yeah very
tough
so in the time it takes to cook that
spaghetti the sauce is ready
yeah it is chili now handy a little tip
just give it a roll like that right
this releases the seeds so you can
discard them easily
[Music]
i mean you guys eat well don't you yeah
yeah you don't have to follow a strict
diet do you
no everything in moderation is what you
know that's what it's
see that's the about kind of food that
we need
right recipe took eating fast here chili
pasta
pancetta leeks and mushrooms
and if you can't get hold of pancetta
bacon
is absolutely fine chop the leeks finely
and add to the bacon
i mean the ultimate goal is um a gold
medal in beijing yeah
yeah four letters that would be better
i'll win one in beijing and defend it in
london i mean the chinese
in your hometown your own country
hosting the olympics
after three minutes add some creme
fraiche which lightens the dish
that's fast isn't it add some grated
parmesan and finish with chopped parsley
that's the kind of time scale that we're
working on so that's perfect
[Music]
recipe three this one's good panic
chicken goat cheese pine nuts and runner
beans
good runner beans in garlic
pine nuts in okay rosemary on there
please chris
take the ingredients out the pan and
prepare the chicken
chicken breast i'm going to butterfly it
okay just keep the knife nice and flat
and just open it up cutting the chicken
this way leaves the breast thinner
and therefore it cooks quicker
that looks that beautiful that's a
really nice
dry goat cheese and at work we keep them
in the freezer and perfect for finishing
pasta it's a great tip because they
never go off
this is not boring is it oh no we can't
rely on time as an excuse to not look
after ourselves no no all three you're
happy with
of course this one i like particularly
we've got the world championship coming
up
the end of the summer yeah i just hope
the [ __ ] your times are faster
at the world championships
golden how are you very well thank you
how are you well it was fine
one time when it all arrived it was nice
do you want our honest opinion
of course i want your honest opinion the
cheese flavor overpowered the fish
if you must use the parmesan next time
great
don't want cubes or parmesan on there
simple produce yep
simply prepared are you gonna pay for it
yes that's the most important not
everyone on the table is but i would
oh my god what are you not paying for
them all you're telling me how it should
be done yes that's how it should be done
[ __ ] it come with me yeah two seconds
yeah you want me do you want a lesson
absolutely definitely yes here we go
let's go
here we go right ladies this is a money
diner
to make up yeah for his negativity he's
gonna give us a hand with the dessert
yeah
this is like something from the like the
new romantic period
ladies you're gonna have to help him
right all right does this turn you on
huh
is one of my favorites can you stop
eating the [ __ ] peaches please yeah
[Music]
panpodeu with carmelized peaches
basically posh eggy bread
and the secret behind this of course is
using old bread if you use old bread it
doesn't absorb all the
nice egg mixture and it gets nice and
crisp on the outside
peaches hot pan
sugar the secret now is to get a little
bit of color
on the peaches but not getting the
caramel too dark
roast once we've got the colour on the
peaches
then we're going to start adding the
butter basil
now the basil just perfumes the caramel
just gives it really nice
light sweet summery flavor
out the sauce for the pan perdue
a really nice fresh vibrant raspberry
coulis
sugar lemon straight onto the mixer
blitz
[Music]
and then get the bottom of your ladle
and just run that around
sieve lovely
eggy bread is very very simple eggs
vanilla smell absolutely delicious
icing sugar milk
cream whisk so we've got this really
nice
sweetened fresh vanilla custard mint
that's ready for the brioche i'm gonna
cut lengthways
nice big long slices
hot pan bread in and then back out
not too long into the pan
up and over and it's literally done
in seconds
[Applause]
get my cooling down one side mint
icing sugar pan purdue with caramelized
peaches and raspber cooling
done that is the perfect summer on a
plate
let's do one at a time and we'll do it
together yes one slice
is not being on the generation game i'm
a dive yes that's
okay in nicely
peaches in that's it you caramelize them
in good
good water all right ladies go
[ __ ] okay good that's nice mine's ready
chef yeah right good on to the board
please
right jonathan you're going to do the
bread yes yeah the girls can do the best
keep cooking yeah
absolutely one no hold on we've got 49
more to do
[ __ ] that a little bit of battle if i
wanted to work
just just a little bit i wouldn't have
bought my bath do it right ladies let's
go
joe keep that stuff in here jonathan
trust me you've lost weight already
you've only been here this is easy
i thought it was going to be difficult
right at least that's to burn there now
down yes not that that's too dark there
you go quick
on in again okay jonathan keep it going
yes thank you gordon yes jeff
i don't mind saying yes chef for saying
hi to ramsay i draw the liner
okay chef i made a smiley face with the
butter in the pan
here we go lost about three stones
well i think i found it a little bit of
cream on top maz
okay that's cool what are you happy with
yep are you happy with them fresh pasta
on there
five yes service please
surely they've eaten enough out they're
the greedy pigs aren't they i'm so happy
you're sweating
last time you did that you were
interviewing funny
well credit looking good lisa you've
perfected it now hasn't she
come and cooked for you that's fine
hold on i'm being harassed i said you
want me to come and cook for you
oh come and cook for you oh that's a far
less interesting proposition
now we've got four more tables to send
yes we must have done fifty dollars
come on shed come on jonathan
i'm getting tired
next on the menu sarah and i await the
final verdict
how'd it go uh we went anywhere
my lamb gavin says goodbye to his mum
and jonathan ross
joins the police lineup this is a big
moment bring it on bring it on
welcome back to the f-word now time to
find out who's won the recipe challenge
and who's cocked it up
oh he didn't he's very good right
generous portion yes no skimping
and we'll plate it up shall we okay rice
is there yep
you make a well in the middle or you
don't exactly
now feeling confident yeah do you serve
sour cream
no i don't know right you're happy with
that can i take this all my freezer
yeah right john baptist please
sour cream screw it on yes yeah okay
sarah's
gordon's good ali ah
hi hi how are you very well thank you
first dish english number two
thank you thank you thank you
not too spicy though it's quite sweet
doesn't actually taste like it's got
that much chili in it
and i think they're baked beans yeah
that's what you can taste in it sort of
like to eat
that tastes more like tomatoes it's like
bringing the flavor through i detect
quite a lot of salt
in this uh right don't look all smurf
and arrogant and french cocky how'd it
go
uh we went very well very very well yeah
obviously yeah it always goes well yeah
well done gordon yeah christ almighty
oh dear you know well done thank you do
me a favor
yeah yeah [ __ ] about my kids excellent
thank you
i'm still no closer to finding out what
happened to charlotte
[Music]
but i've now got to concentrate on
getting gavin back home
farmer may has come to help me relocate
him
what a [ __ ] night hey sorry
yeah it was awful well i'm afraid you
lose something far minimum frets
a quick look on the three you know these
don't look damaged at all you know
they haven't got hold of these so you're
happy with their condition oh yes
definitely
yeah they're looking well gavin's not
enough to feed 50 diners of clarity's
so to keep him company and crucially
give me enough meat for my restaurant
may's brought me two new lambs
at 13 weeks gavin is getting too old to
keep suckling from his mother
so he has to be weaned or separated from
the parent
splitting up a lamb and his mother is a
harsh reality of farming
so he's going to be a bit of a peculiar
yeah you can spot here
for him though yeah he's you know he's
calling they're calling for each other
now
we'll put those through the ceiling and
yeah
may has taken the use back to wales
drive carefully yes
take care thank you
and i'm taking the lambs to my garden in
london where hugh early wooden stool is
waiting
you've now got the situation where these
two new incomers
they're used to the welsh hills i'm not
going to send them anywhere else they're
staying in my back gun what you have to
hope
is that um he's gonna teach them yeah
how to stay calm how to stay calm in
suburbia
welcome home listen unfortunately we've
got some
bad news to explain charlotte
got eaten eaten by what we don't know it
may be a dog or a wild cat
it's the white one okay listen
i'm not blaming your cat for eating them
okay no oh dear
they seem to be setting down well
they're i think they're settling down
all right
and i think the really encouraging thing
is that they look like a trio already
that's a little flock you've got there a
nice little flock of three
can tell which one is the original very
easy to identify look gavin's got the
full tail
and the other two girls are not hard to
tell him apart no he's not hard at all
you know what we did last time i was
here when when gavin was only small
yes we gave charlotte and gavin a hill
that's right
i think we've got to give him a bigger
hill
hugh's pulling out all the stops to make
sure the lambs are as happy as possible
in their final weeks over here bit nice
that's a snug fit
not this bloody roof again is that the
front could be
yeah jack or is it the back let's get
the grass on the roof
this one should end up with utopia
jordan just for me make a noise like a
sheep oh man
the same man get some more glasses
[Applause]
check it out phase one
that's your man isn't it yeah that's
kevin yeah he's home do you still think
i'm mad
later that evening all three lambs
finally reached the top of the mountain
how cool is that huh cool
you look happy what do you think yeah of
course yeah but you're not happy about
your grass
that will grow listen grass will always
grow yeah and lamb is delicious
that's the only thing you've got to
think about tonight when you get back to
bed they'll hear you
last tables yes jonathan yes
all right six are the best now yes okay
here we go
oh come on baby don't do that to me this
is your table there oh shut up
rashford please pop nice ladies
oh well done that was fast i've never
seen you work so hard
[Laughter]
oh
[Applause]
the basil really complemented it it's
not something that i would think of
putting with a dessert but
it was great i loved it definitely pay
for this i'll definitely have it again
as well [ __ ] egb yes
come on so ladies for the starter 34 out
of 50.
yeah yes yeah yeah pretty good yeah not
perfect but
not bad yes main course 2950
not good enough this yes is a big
moment bring it on bring it on come on
ladies
for dessert yes out of 50 diners
48 have agreed to pound
[Applause]
well done bloody good work you know that
[ __ ] good work
the total is yeah out of 150
is 111 i'm so sorry
you will not be coming back to clara the
second best so far
[ __ ] close yes
you've earned the right to remain silent
yeah
[ __ ] off for a beer yes well done come
here
all right great job um
simple produce simply prepared
[ __ ] off